...
-Quand t'es pas sage,
on te donne une fessée ?
-Non, on me puni. Je suis
privé de télé ou de dessert.
-On me donne une fessée.
-Qui te donne une fessée ?
-Maman.
-Tu acceptes ça facilement ?
-Non, pas toujours.
-Quand tu auras des enfants,
ils auront des fessés ?
-Oui.
-On doit pas donner des fessées ?
-Non.
-Quand tes parents sont durs
avec toi, ils ont raison ou pas ?
-Ca dépend. Parfois je trouve
qu'ils ont raison, et parfois pas.
-Ils me donnent des fessées ?
-Des fessées comment ?
-Eh ben...
...
-Tu es contre ou pour la fessée ?
-Contre.
-Tu pleures quand on t'en donne ?
-J'essaie de ne pas pleurer.
-Tu penses que tes parents
ont raison ou tort ?
-Qu'ils ont tord.
-On me punie de sortir.
-De sortir de quoi ?
-D'aller chez des amis.
-On te donne jamais de fessée ?
-Non.
-Pas de gifle ?
-Tu n'aimerais pas
qu'on te frappe ?
-Heu... Non.
-Tu ferais quoi si on te frappait ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Je me débattrais.
-Tu feras quoi quand
tu auras des enfants ?
-Rien du tout.
-Ils feront ce qu'ils veulent ?
-Ben oui.
Ca dépend. Peut-être
qu'ils deviendront gâtés, à force.
-On se dispute, c'est tout.
Mais on ne me tape jamais.
-Qui dispute, ton père ou ta mère ?
-Les deux.
Ca dépend des jours.
-T'es souvent pas sage ?
-Non, pas souvent.
-T'es plutôt sage ?
-Oui.
-Mais jamais de fessée ?
-Oh non.
Ou alors,
ça arrive rarement.
-Tu fais quoi
quand ça arrive ?
-Je me planque,
c'est tout.
-On me tape ?
-Où ?
-Dans les fesses.
-Et ça te fait mal ?
-Ca dépend.
Quand on me tape fort, oui.
-Tu pleures ?
-Quelques fois.
-Quand t'es pas sage,
on te fais quoi ?
-On me tape.
-Où ?
-Ca dépend.
-Raconte-moi.
-A la figure,
sur les joues.
-Sur les fesses aussi ?
-Non.
-Comment tu réagis après ?
-Je ne pleure jamais.
-On me donne une fessée.
-Une grosse fessée ?
-Non, une petite.
-Et tu fais quoi ?
-Après je me cache.
-Quand tu auras des enfants,
tu leur donneras des fessées ?
-Non, je les bagarrerai.
-Ah bon ?
Tu bagarreras tes enfants ?
-Oui, quand
j'aurai un petit frère.
-Non, à tes enfants à toi.
Tu leur donneras des fessées ?
-Hum.
-Tu seras un méchant papa ?
-Oh non !
-Ah bon... Salut, cow-boy.